after 497 days
the wait for the country's saturday park
runners is finally over
at 500 locations across the country an
estimated 100
000 runners took part in the events
which were first started
17 years ago it's so exciting to come
back it's been a long time out i think
uh 70 saturdays we've missed
since march last year so it's been a
long time coming
i think everyone here and and all the
emails we've had and messages we're
so excited to come back and get people
turning up that have never run before
but they get the confidence to walk
cheered on by our marshals and so it's
just a great time that everybody has on
a saturday as well as feeling good and
feeling
good about themselves because they've
made the effort to walk or run round the
course
brian platt is 85 now and has taken part
in over 500 park runs
and volunteered at hundreds of others
he's delighted that the events
are back up and running well it's
they're all personal best
getting around is a personal best for me
for the other runners the chance to
exercise more socially
provides a welcome change we've come all
the way from sheffield uh because our
local park room where
uh i'm a run directors close for another
event so it's just nice to
go try a different route meet other
people and uh yeah
have fun and get fit as well it's great
to see people not seeing any just
walk down and run with them yes very
nice just grateful mental health and
obviously the physical side of it as
well so after 70 saturdays without their
park runs
the runners are back in force young and
old families individuals socializing
again
in their tens of thousands right across
the country and they are glad to be back
the fastest runners took a little over
17 minutes to complete this
5k course brian took
just a little longer well i made it in
one piece
it's been so nice just to get back and
people push you along i've had so many
people going
go on izzy you're smashing it it's
absolutely fantastic i mean
i've been here for so long it's great to
be out in the open doors to get some
you know fresh air in your lungs and
more importantly it's the social side of
it you know meeting with people
the local government association says
the events make a vital contribution to
people's mental
and physical well-being the runners well
they're just glad to be back
fraser moore to sky news marple
you